hey youtubers it's Charlie so arrow
season 4 is back confirms some of the
things that we thought about what was
going on between the flashbacks
present-day and we found out how they
changed the show they've been teasing
that they were gonna do things very very
differently this season in terms of
structure so here we go what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna start by explaining the
way they changed the show like they
fundamentally changed the way the show
works so careful for spoilers from the
episode starting off with the flashbacks
what Marc Guggenheim said is different
about season four is that what they used
to do is they would have characters from
the flashbacks that would transition to
present-day they're not going to do that
the flashbacks are gonna be their own
thing they're just gonna zoom at eclis
inform what's going on in present day
let the darkness in that's that's what
it's all about it seems like some of the
characters in present day have already
done that as per that ending twist but
the other part structurally is that now
it's much more fully integrated with the
flash like they talked about the high
speed rail they're metaphorically and
literally connecting those two cities in
those characters so we have Grant Gustin
at the end of the episode with a flash
four to six months from episode one
there's a total gut punch ending but
what it's doing is it's showing you the
potential outcome based on what ends up
happening this season so the road drama
is finding out whether or not they can
change that or if that outcome is a
fixed point in time just to use Doctor
Who terms but let's get into top 10 WTF
moments we'll dig through it and we'll
talk about all the crazy stirrings
including the Hal Jordan stuff oh and
just a quick reminder I am doing the
reverse flash ring giveaway this week
I'm moving away two rings all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video starting
with number 10 Oliver and Felicity are
living in Ivy town now if you don't know
where this is this is where Ivy
University is it's the home of the Ray
Palmer atom in the comics there's also a
bunch of other firestorm stuff that
happens here it's just one of the many
notable DC Comics cities like metropolis
or Gotham City on to number nine
speaking of ownership
Felicity is now rolling in cash as CEO
of Palmer tech although it seems kind of
tenuous at best right now because
there's a board that's trying to
challenge her control yes all of the
characters think that Ray Palmer is dead
but obviously we know all about the atom
we've read the comics he really just
shrunk down at the end of season three I
have no idea how the show is gonna
surface him but at some point he has to
go on legends of tomorrow
oh so he has to figure out a way to
regrow himself so expect at least one
episode before the mid-season finale on
arrow to address Ray Palmer to like you
know fixed to get him back to normal
size but part of the fun of Oliver and
Felicity's lives now just like the
really awkward domesticity that they
have going on and for those that are
wondering the tattoo that Oliver had
removed is actually the dragon that
looked just like shadows tattoo from
back on the island he's kind of like
wiping shadow from his life I don't need
it anymore
he got it to remember shado it's just a
way for the show to say that he has
gotten rid of some of his demons he
still does have that Russian Bratva
tattoo that denotes his rank as captain
he's a really high ranking officer in
the Russian mafia so so we might see a
little bit of that this year spew which
number eight Oliver is in Coast City in
the flashbacks at least when they pick
up trying to be the hood if you remember
the progression from douchebag college
boy Oliver to green arrow obviously the
end of this episode he started out as
Oliver turned into the hood first that
was his first persona then he became the
arrow and obviously now he's the green
arrow so he is the hood in these
flashbacks as of right now and we
finally get Amanda Waller back hopefully
we'll see her more this season but he's
on the island so I have no idea yes you
definitely did see a Jordan jacket now
that could be Hal Jordan I think that's
what they want you to think they
wouldn't have put that in there if they
didn't want you to think that but they
can't really do Green Lantern on arrow
so I'm not expecting to see a whole lot
of Green Lantern stuff but anytime
they're in Coast City they will put
references to Green Lantern things in
there on the number 7 this five months
away team arrow is kind of like team
Diggle and Diggle has his new costume
the one that Thea's wearing was the same
one from the end of the last season it's
just like a modified version of Roy's
costume who is still trying to sell the
idea of red arrow I loved it so much
that Thea is kind of like this Damian
Wayne type character now just completely
going apeshit completely ignoring the
reality of the situation just like I
don't give a crap about morality but she
still really hates the idea that they're
calling her speedy the best answer I
have for that was the end of last season
where she kind of said it hopefully to
Oliver and he's a shut her down he's
like I'm pretty sure I already told
everybody to call you speedy so if he
thinks she's gonna be turning into red
arrow no she is the Mia Dearden speedy
her name is Thea Dearden Queen
what's going on here is that they're
hijacking Kord industries weapons
they're just damian darhk-- and hayver
just arming up
I feel like Ted Kord is being put
forward as the Steve Jobs of the DC
Universe because he makes a really
awesome phone if you guys saw there was
some viral marketing for Batman V
Superman it was like this Lex Luthor
thing where he made this speech and we
found out that he's Lex Luthor jr. but
he also referenced Ted Kord in that so
Ted Kord is a very big figure in the
movies and on the TV show but I'm not
expecting to see him on the TV show
anytime soon
we'll just be seeing a lot of people
steal from him on to number six meet
your hive and damian darhk-- so let's
start with the big guy damian darhk--
big Teen Titans villain from the comics
but he really only appeared in like an
eighth issue miniseries so he's really
not that big of a character in the
comics arrow has kind of taken some
liberties he doesn't get too involved
with mysticism but in the episode Damian
says I want things to be ready for when
my associates get here obviously hive
big villain organization is gonna have
other big villains that are a part of it
that could also include Vandal Savage
Vandal Savage of course not going to
show up on arrow till episode eight so
that could be the timeline for when he's
trying to make the city ready just put a
bookmark in that we really don't have
enough information to start positing
what's going on with vandal savage's
involvement in all this but for the most
part just think of hive is like an elite
version of the League of Assassins with
more high-tech gear on the number 5
shocking twist number 1 Quentin Lance
has been working with hive this whole
time we don't we don't know if it's been
five months we don't know how long we
just know that his relationship with
damian darhk-- predates episode 1 so
presumably at some point Black Canary
will probably find out what her father's
been up to and why he did it it seems
like what happened is Damian's arc
rolled into town and just said look
there's no way you could fight me so you
can either work for me or I can kill you
but you let the darkness in the darkness
changes you if you rewind to season 3
you remember that was actually a line of
dialogue that was uttered during the
Black Canary story arc it was all about
Laurel letting the darkness in and now
Quentin is the one that's letting the
darkness in I mean obviously the the
metaphoric crosses all the characters in
different ways like damian darhk-- who
literally lets the darkness in with
those you know those weird tattoos and
runes on his arms the other characters
like
via Diggle letting the darkness in
metaphorically like emotionally when I
saw this twist I got so excited this is
like the best possible thing for Paul
Blackthorne he's an amazing drama actor
he does great genre stuff but his
Quentin Lance storyline in season 3 just
didn't do it for me like he just he
didn't have a very exciting storyline
season 4 in general is all about the
nature of family in what you do for
family you know is your family the
people you're born to or is it the
family you choose for yourself but on at
number 4 Oliver and Diggle kind of heal
the family of team arrow so now they're
team green arrow although it's much more
egalitarian and if you remember they
were kind of running the city by
committee at the beginning of the
episode that's kind of how team arrow is
gonna function this year - it used to be
oliver building a team around him now
it's kind of more of a shared
responsibility kind of thing so Diggle
and Oliver will be sharing a lot of the
leadership responsibilities but as much
as Diggle was really upset about him he
gets that call to action from Lyla where
it's like you know get over it I've
forgiven Oliver you should - don't be a
[ __ ] so as of that call to action that
Oliver had at the end of the episode
where he hijacks the emergency broadcast
line
I don't think Diggle is completely
forgiven him but they're not gonna have
like a lot of internal drama like that
was kind of meant to cut that off like
saying like this isn't gonna be a thing
every single episode we're not gonna be
fighting all the time so of all the
family problems are gonna be happening
this season most of them are gonna be
between blood family members so like
Thea and Oliver are gonna be having some
problems because she's gone super dark
Quentin and Laurel gonna be having a lot
of problems because he is gone super
dark on to number three Oliver gets
dumped back on the island we don't know
a ton about the season four flashbacks
only that the big villain and the
flashbacks will be bare and blitzkrieg
I'm assuming that a lot of it at least
the first half of the season will take
place on the island but I don't know if
he's gonna be bouncing back and forth
between Coast City in the island
sometimes the only way out is through so
Oliver kind of working through his
darkness by going into the mouth of hell
which is kind of twisting the metaphor
because Lian Yu actually means purgatory
on to number two Felicity unveils
Cisco's latest creation the green arrow
costume which probably has all kinds of
tech that we'll learn about it's just
one more way that they're tying both
shows together you know like I said they
have the high speed rail we had Barry
Allen at the end of the episode all
kinds of stuff tying these shows
together
the costume itself looks pretty awesome
I mean they unveiled it at comic-con so
we've had a couple months to think about
it the gauntlets look a little bit weird
but I'm really just excited to see like
what's underneath the hood like what the
suit can do we do know right now that it
does not offer him any protection from
damien darhk's abilities and actually
this damien darhk's seen that he has
this fight scene is just to let you know
that arrow as a show has activated final
boss form but damian darhk-- himself is
not completely unkillable he's not
completely invincible
that's why Diggle is able to tranq him
just a little bit every time Oliver
tries to fight him he's probably gonna
get his ass handed to him like they need
to learn more about the nature of damien
darhk's abilities before they can fight
them it looks like he has some sort of
connection with this totem I'm wondering
if either he's going to turn into an
actual demon like a literal
personification of darkness or if team
arrow is gonna like smash the eye like
they have to do something to neutralize
his abilities a certain point but that
seems like it's so far off like you know
probably a season finale but if the
season is all about what happens when
you let the darkness in then presumably
darkness will just overtake damian
darhk-- in a really bad way I know
everybody would love to see the demon
Etrigan I don't think we'd ever see him
on arrow though but now that Constantine
is no longer a show at least they have a
chance but finally on to my number one
WTF moment of course it looks like a
member of team arrow has died six months
into the future and just plotting this
timeline that would put it at the end of
the season so it looks like they're
flashing forward to like episode 23 I've
heard it said that the writers are still
deciding who is gonna go in that grave
like it could change depending on which
way the story goes this season okay I
don't know who was in the casket grave
tombstone etc literally I don't they
don't write like every single episode
before they start shooting episode 1 but
they only have up to I think like the
mid-season finale right now they
probably have an idea for who they want
in that grave but that could change in
the back half of the season right now I
think it could either be Diggle
it could be Quentin or it could be
Felicity I think it's a little
misleading to assume that it's felicity
just because that scene came right after
that moment with Oliver but think about
what Oliver said when he was talking to
Barry there would have been a time that
I would have thought this would have
been my fault bringing this darkness to
the
city and that's taken from a scene that
he had with Quentin so I think it's more
likely that Quentin is in the grave and
he is just like really upset about what
happened to Quentin like the dark path
that he was set on this is the big
debate that we're gonna have this week
let me know in the comments who is in
that grave like why do you think that it
is that person the reason that I don't
think that it's Thea is because they
killed her last season it would be like
them recycling that plot all over again
dude like why don't we just dump her in
the lazarus pit and if it were felicity
then oliver would probably be
inconsolable like he would probably just
be like like a melty pile of flesh and
in this scene it just looks like he has
great regret it doesn't look like
someone that he was getting ready to get
married to just died but at this point
remembered the writers have not decided
who's in the grave so so whoever you
come up with you're not wrong like there
is no wrong answer at this point I am
gonna do a Q&A for this so leave all
your questions in the comments on this
and on my flash episode 1 video that's
gonna post after my agents of shield
video I still need to catch up on that
because that was an awesome episode this
week - be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a couple other
trailers for like Jessica Jones there's
a Sherlock trailer I'll try to do that
on Friday so I'm gonna get through
agents of shield and arrow flash stuff
tomorrow here's the other big question
that I want you guys to answer for me
two of the two premieres arrow in the
flesh who do you think had the better
episode 1 even though they're both
amazing personally I think that arrow
had the better episode like just the way
it was constructed the narrative the way
they changed the show so even if you're
just talking about who had the most
improved episode like from season to
season
I think arrow did the better job even
though both arrow and flash were amazing
this week I am so excited about this
season of arrow in flash so like I said
is it actually gonna be like one big
story stretched out over three shows
when you throw it legends of tomorrow in
there - so yes you do need to watch
arrow and flash each week to keep up in
case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for my flash episode 1 video
from last night and you can click here
for agents of shield I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post the video
thank you so much for watching everybody
big green arrow high-five I'll see you
guys tomorrow